[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to
have as my guest is barry weiss
who i haven't seen since she interviewed
me for the aspen ideas fair
and that was i think three years ago a
long time
barry is a journalist and the author of
how to fight anti-semitism which won a
2019 national
jewish book award from 2017 to 2020
weiss was an opinion writer and editor
at the new york times
before that she was an op-ed and book
review editor at the wall street journal
and a senior editor at tablet magazine
she's the winner of the inaugural pair
all mark award in recognition of her
moral courage
and the winner of the reason
foundation's 2018 bastiat prize
which honors writing that best
demonstrates the importance
of freedom with originality wit and
eloquence
that's a lovely combination in 2019
vanity fair
called weiss the times star opinion
writer
despite that barry now writes on sub
stack
follow her work at
barryweiss.substack.com
thanks very much for agreeing to talk to
me today
mary it's a pleasure to have you here
it's a pleasure to see you jordan
i've been exceptionally curious about
exactly what happened with you
since i i was out of sync with the
entire world for a good long time but i
did know that
you left the new york times to start
on your own start as a independent
journalist on substance and that's quite
the
turn of events that say especially given
that vanity fair called you the time
star opinion writer
that feels like 100 years ago yeah
it's not so long ago though is it but
many things have happened in the interim
so should we start with something easy
like just
exactly what the hell happened at the
new york times sure
okay sure well i guess i should start
with um
the what drove me to come to the new
york times in the first place
i came to the new york times following
you know the
well it was shocking in the context of
the new york times the
victory of donald trump in the 2016
election
there was a brief period of
soul-searching that happened
after trump won i would say inside the
new york times but inside the legacy
media in general
and there was a sense of wow you know
our job is to hold up a mirror to the
country as it is
and we've sort of failed our readers you
know we haven't
exposed them let's say to views or to
the
zeitgeist outside of places like you
know the upper west side and berkeley
and so in a way i was an intellectual
diversity
hire along with brett stevens i had been
at the wall street journal editorial
page
um for years um in two different stints
and
as viewers may or may not know i you
know
the wall street journal editorial page
is conservative it's motto is free
people free markets
and i was always the squish in the
context of
the journal's editorial page i was
always like on the leftmost flank
so you were a diversity hirer at the
wall street journal as well
i've always just been on a fringe in one
place or another
and i think a weird to be fringe and in
the center
well not weird i feel like that's
increasingly where anyone
who's in the center is these days you're
politically homeless
and you're sort of forced to choose
between one side
or another uh it's maybe unique in so
far as
you know the kind of jobs that i had but
inc
the the number of people i know who feel
that way who feel
politically homeless who feel like they
have to sort of
contort themselves to fit into one of
these two tribes is growing by the
second
and so in that sense i don't think my
experience was that unique
what so anyway i get to the new york
times
and i i want to be clear like i didn't
go into the new york times
naive uh you know i read the paper for
years i
saw you know what's obviously its
liberal bias
but i felt fundamentally like the paper
was still
trying to adhere to what it claims to
be all about in its mission statement
you know pursuing the truth
even when it's hard you know the famous
ad that the times has the truth is hard
it's all it's all over tote bags um
striving for
that tells you how hard it is right
right exactly striving for objectivity
even though we know none of us are
objective um
you know telling people the truth even
when it's inconvenient
so wright still nested inside this idea
that journalists for example could
represent a viewpoint that was actually
objectively true rather than
expressing inevitably expressing their
their association with an arbitrary
power structure
i mean it was still an enlightenment
idea as far as you were concerned that
reigned at the times
right and and specifically on the
editorial page and you know i was an
op-ed editor
so you know what the public saw that i
did was write columns but the majority
of what my job was
was to commission and edit op-eds from
people who wouldn't otherwise think of
the new york times as their natural
political home so that meant
conservatives
god forbid it meant libertarians it
meant heterodox thinkers it meant
high schoolers and first-time writers
and dissidents you know across the arab
world which is a subject i'm
particularly passionate about so my job
was specifically
to expose our readers to views that
would not otherwise naturally appear on
the op-ed page of the new york times
okay and that was an explicit condition
of your hiring
everyone knew that that was to become my
job description
okay so you weren't a fifth column or if
you were it was something that everybody
had agreed upon
yeah the goal was for me to to bring in
pieces that would otherwise make
maybe my even my desk mates
uncomfortable
and so why did they pick you do you
think
and why did the wall street journal pick
you to begin with those are very
difficult positions to attain
and how old were you when you started
with the wall street journal so
i started at the wall street journal i
had a fellowship there the summer
that i graduated uh from columbia
university
the way that i got to the wall street
journal is very serendipitous
i you know was very much a
i would say center left liberal when i
was a student in college and
but i was very passionate on the subject
of israel and
fighting anti-semitism which is the book
that i ended up writing i sort of had
been writing that book for a very long
time
and i would frequently host debates on
campus
with the socialist group or the sort of
anti-zionist group
and there was an uh an older gentleman
that would come to some of my events
and one day you know he definitely was
not an undergraduate
and one day he came up to me and said
you know my name is charles stevens
you need to meet my son brett stevens he
works at the wall street journal and
they have this amazing summer internship
i had never really heard of brett i had
never heard of the wall street journal
but that was how i ended up getting
there it started with a summer
internship called the bartley fellowship
that's still in existence today
um and like anything you know i worked
really hard
and worked my way up into into a job and
so
that internship became became my first
job
what did you study at columbia i studied
history
i wanted to be a middle east studies
major but found that what was happening
in classrooms was not um
was not was not conducive to
uh exploration it was okay so i wanted
to i want to do a little diff
a little divergence here so i want to
tell you a story
i spoke with yonmi park about three
weeks ago
and she wrote in order to live
now she wrote in order to live well
because she had
a horrendous life that's one reason even
though one of the things she told me
while i interviewed her was that she'd
met people who
whose life was so much worse than hers
that she felt blessed which was quite
the bloody
catastrophe of a statement i'll tell you
and anyways
um her book ends in 2015.
so i asked her what she had been doing
since 2015.
and she went to colombia to take a
humanities degree
i talked to her about this recently too
oh okay no but go ahead
well she told me yeah well she said
i mean i thought that was quite
remarkable he had this young woman who
was raised under the most horrifying
totalitarian conditions well not the
most because that's a deep hell hole but
bad enough and then was a slave in china
along with her mother and
then you know managed to get to south
korea and then
did all her pre-university education
basically in one year
virtually hospitalized herself with
effort and
during that time she read um animal farm
by george orwell and
that sort of motivated her to write but
and then she went to university in south
korea which is no joke it's very
competitive place and
and and then she went to colombia to
take humanity's degree which in her
words was part of her father's wish that
she become educated and so she went to
this stellar institution
in the center of what's arguably the
greatest city on earth to pursue
the sort of enlightenment
to pursue the spark that had been lit in
here by orwell let's say
and by her introduction to freedom and i
said well how was it at columbia
and she said it was a complete waste of
time and money
and like she's a reasonable person she's
not actually prone to statements like
that it quite
surprised me and i said surely that
can't be
the case i mean you know that's a
damning global statement you must have
had one professor
one course that spoke to you and she
said well there was a human biology
course where i studied evolution but
even it got politically correct by the
end and i felt that
i was never able to say anything i
actually thought
and i pushed her and she was adamant it
was that it was
catastrophe going to colombia and that
she felt i hope i'm not exaggerating
this but i do believe that this
is what she was attempting to put
forward
she didn't feel any freer in her speech
and actions at columbia than she did in
bloody north korea
and i didn't wasn't dancing with glee
hearing that you know
noting that my prognostications about
political correctness and
universities had manifested themselves
it's
terribly shocking to me and terribly
saddening that that's actually the case
and i've interviewed some older people
recently they'd be my age who
look back on their humanities education
with nothing but
nostalgia and the fondest of memories
for the professors that opened up their
lives and and started them on their
careers
great journalists in canada and
businessmen as well
jacob willink as well who took an
english literature degree and was
was illuminated by it what was it like
for you at columbia
you know jordan it was a mix um
on the one ha colombia has and who knows
how much longer this will be around but
it has what's called the core curriculum
it's basically a study of the classics
freshman year you read
classical literature uh sophomore year
you
study classical philosophy those that
was the reason that i went to colombia
and those classes for me were exactly
what you described
that spark that you and me felt when she
read george orwell
i i absolutely why were they that for
you
well first of all i had never read those
books before
um and you know knew who plato was
vaguely knew socrates was you know
knew go down the line you know had heard
who virginia woolf was
all of these books like they were
soul expanding and the it happened to be
that i got
extremely lucky especially in that
second year course that i described the
philosophy course
to have a teacher who um was genuinely
committed
to i think what education is supposed to
be about at its best
and what is it supposed to be about at
its best as far as you're concerned what
did it do for you
teaching me how to think and think
critically and read a text
and allow it
i mean at the deepest moments have it
transformed me
rather than what i encountered for
example in the middle east studies
department which was like
more like hearing a preacher i mean it
was more just
propaganda what do you think the
difference is between propaganda and
education
i mean especially i'm asking you this
because the claim
one of the claims that is is splitting
our culture
down the middle is that there is no
there is nothing but propaganda
essentially
and you just think the propaganda on
your side is the truth because it serves
your purposes to believe that
so it's very very important to make a
distinction between propaganda and
education now you
had two different kinds of classes as
far as you're concerned
one of them you describe as opening
yourself up and the other you describe
as being preached at
okay so what what's the difference there
why didn't i just describe the
difference
well i i not so much on the preaching
side
what were you being compelled to think
in the middle east
okay first of all you're making the case
that you were compelled to think in
one set of classes what were you
compelled to think
well let me give you an example um the
course that i was thinking about in my
mind as i just described this was a
course
called you know topics in middle east
studies so it's the entire region of the
middle east for
going back thousands of years in a sort
of
general 101 course it was part of a
requirement if you wanted to
be a to continue on in the major
and that course basically you
here's what you had to accept that the
soul sort of source of
maladies in what i think we all can
agree
is a very complicated and
blood-soaked region of the world are all
the result
of essentially european or american
colonialism
that everything goes back to that core
idea
and that even things like let's say in
india
you know widow burning could be
connected to colonialism
even things like honor killing could be
everything had to do with this sort of
one lens with which you could understand
an extremely complicated thing and then
the second part and
this this is again like i think often
times this is the case if you know
something about one particular topic
like let's say a lot about it
and and you don't know a lot about saudi
arabia or iran
or any of the other places you're
studying but you know a lot about this
one place and for me that was israel
and you hear that what you're being
taught about it is so out of line
with reality then you start being
skeptical about everything else the
person is saying
and that was very much the case with me
that you know
first of all israel is one of you know
dozens of countries in the middle east
but
it was obsessed on in the course and the
one
text we were asked to read about this
complicated
very interesting place the history that
goes back thousands of years
which is the cradle of western
civilization was
a book by um a guy called maxime
rodinson i
recommend people look it up called
israel colon
a zionist colonial settler state
question mark
and suffice it to say the question mark
was superfluous
and um everything was just sort of
driving
toward the i felt the political view of
the professor that was teaching the
course whereas
you know in in um contrast the
philosophy course that i was describing
to you or even
i'm thinking about an intellectual
history class that i took
i didn't really know what my professor
thought and
we were always obsessed with like what
did they really think and that made it
um it just felt like they were trying to
as much as possible
remove their own views to teach
texts and ideas to us in the most
capacious way possible now it turns out
with the intellectual history course you
know that professor is now
on twitter and i i see what he thinks um
and it's very much
you know not my view of the world but i
really admire the fact that he
that i didn't know that when i took his
class and that i was able to sort of
come to my own positions
without feeling like if i wasn't
parroting what he said
that i would somehow be punished um
whether it was you know in my in the
grade that i received or in
the seminar section part of of the
lecture course
so to me that's a really important
decision okay so so there's a couple of
things there that i think might be worth
highlighting
or there they strike me as worth
highlighting anyways is
i wrote a chapter in my last book which
is beyond order
called abandon ideology and
one of the propositions that
makes up the argument in that chapter is
that
you have to be aware of unifactorial
explanations
for complex phenomena is that if you
look at anything
perhaps you might look at the wage gap
say between men and women the purported
wage gap well
the probability that there's one exactly
reason that that occurs well first of
all you have to ask the question to
begin with
is the gap real there's a measurement
issue there and so you can take that
apart because you don't have to accept
the proposition that the phenomena even
exists to begin with that happens in
psychology all the time
where people will use a term in common
parlance
but not necessarily be able to translate
that into some
like objective reality like for example
we experience an emotion the emotion of
shame
but it isn't obvious that there's a
shame system
neurobiologically maybe it's the
interaction of a variety of
neurobiological systems whereas for
anxiety there looks like there's a
neurobiological system and for play
there's a neurobiological system and so
there's not necessarily a one-to-one
correspondence between a word and the
objective world so you can always
question that but then when you look at
a complicated phenomena
the probability that there's multiple
reasons for its existence or even if
there isn't that there's multiple
theories about the single thing that's
the
cause of its existence that's that's a
necessary part of sophisticated thinking
and so maybe one thing for people to be
aware of
is that a totalizing viewpoint
all of this plethora of complexity is a
consequence of
this one thing and that's the hallmark
that's one of the hallmarks perhaps one
of the hallmarks of propaganda
when it's not utilizing just outright
deceit
and so and then i think there's another
um something that you pointed to more
implicitly which is that
maybe it's also necessary to cast an
extraordinarily skeptical eye
on totalizing theories that identify a
convenient enemy
and a convenient enemy would be someone
that you're clearly not
because it's and and so i've become very
leery of conversations for example where
people rely on the word
they and i don't mean that as a
gender-neutral pronoun i mean
when you talk about that they that are
at fault when they're doing the things
they're doing
you think well it's kind of convenient
that that doesn't include you because a
lot of the really complex problems that
we face
are all our problems and all are doing
in some sense in some broad sense or at
least all our responsibility
so there's the totalizing element
there's the over
and it's so psychologically rewarding
also to do
in some sense to develop a totalizing
theory that
means that you have an explanation for
absolutely everything because with
minimal cognitive
effort you have a map of the entire
world and it means you have a community
i mean i i don't think we can overstate
how comforting it is to feel like you're
part of a tribe
and that you're aligned against those
people over there
yeah well the first part of that might
be beneficial and positive but the
second part
which tends to go along with it is the
danger of that
communal drive you know there is
evidence for example that
people who are high in empathy are much
harsher in their out group evaluations
than people who are low in empathy
because you know we think of empathy as
an untrammeled good well it unites
people and it unites them
with love essentially it's it's
biologically speaking it's a
manifestation of the affiliative circuit
that bonds mother and child and that's
elaborated up into pair bonding for for
adult humans but then it extends out to
those who are your kin that all sounds
lovely and and
positive but you know you don't want to
get between a mother grizzly and her
cubs
so so there's that side of it so
so the the now the prop the distinction
between the propaganda
let's say and a real exploration
a real class a real education i think
hinges on something like exploration so
let's think about these podcasts as an
example i mean
i find a podcast discussion particularly
useful when the two people who are
involved in the discussion
are exploring at the fringes of their
knowledge
and trying to further what they already
know instead of trying to hammer home a
point to convince the
person they're talking to or themselves
or the listener and
in my classes you know when they were
going well i
stepped through a variety of
psychological theories in my personality
class right so it started with freud and
jung and adler and
and rogers and all the great clinicians
and i would put
forward their case as strongly as
possible and then trying to explore what
they meant but
but that wasn't my viewpoint it was it
was an attempt to explore and then i
could pull the students along with it
and
that seems to be much different than
here's the problem
here's the perpetrators it's a soul
and and and you experienced like there
was a phenomenological experience that
you had that
made you contrast those two approaches
yeah and it was also i mean this this
connects it back to your initial
question which is what the hell happened
at the new york times
in a way that answer to that
begins in college because that was
the first time that i started to
encounter
what has been called critical social
justice or
critical race theory or wokeness or what
rodriguez called soft totalitarianism or
or really cultural and moral relativism
to put it more simply
i remember very very clearly getting
into an argument
with another friend also identified as a
feminist
and she was justifying female genital
mutilation to me
because that's other people's culture
and we need to respect it i'm being
crude but that was the basic argument
and i remember thinking what the hell
how can you possibly call yourself a
feminist and believe in defending
the rights of women and believe that
women should be
safe and have equality of opportunity to
men and
also believe that female genital
mutilation can be justified in any
universe
and so it was the first time and it was
very uncomfortable but in a way i'm
grateful for it because
the ideas that i started to encounter
both in classes and also
socially at school those are the ideas
that have now swallowed the culture
and have swallowed the institutions that
are meant to uphold the liberal order
okay and now let's talk about that for a
minute because
why are you so convinced that that's
true like i mean
i it's true that they swallowed
everything yes exactly
exactly right because this is a major
question so
our culture is facing this extreme
division or that's what it appears and
but the question is is it as serious as
it as
as you might perceive it to be or is
that a consequence of the information
sources that you're availing yourself of
and of course this exactly the same
thing applies to me i mean
i saw this coming as far as i'm
concerned you know well
20 years ago 25 years ago but more
particularly five years ago and
you know that's got me in all sorts of
trouble but it seems to me to be
something real and something dangerous
and i'm trying to put my finger on
exactly what it is and to warn people
about it but
it's not like i don't have my doubts
about you know whether this is just my
conspiratorial
idiosyncrasy making itself known in the
world and so
i don't think it's a conspiracy i think
the question is whether or not
the optimists are right and this thing
is a moral panic
and it will burn itself out just like
you know panic around
satanic you know child molesters burned
them
that that burned out in the 1980s in
this country
and maybe in canada too i'm not sure yes
definitely well we always do things a
little less
extremely but we follow along in your
wake right so the question
is like are those people right you know
will wokeness i hate that word but i
don't know what else to call it will it
recede on its own
like a fever that burns itself out or
will it only sort of um
let's say lose the battle over
the culture and over sense making and
over
the elite institutions in america and
more broadly in the west if it meets
another force that pushes against
it i don't see it receding on its own
and the more i look inside
you know certainly the press i have the
front row seat to witness that and we
can talk about it
let's talk about it but education
science
the big tech the hr departments of major
corporations in this country like
it's touching everything and well i got
a notification from my university
department today
they developed a contract for
undergraduates who are going to work in
labs
which seems to me to be completely
unnecessary anyways because that was
something that was always handled by
individual professors but
most of it's just you know care of data
and
and the sorts of things that you might
expect that might be made explicit if
you were going to work in a lab but of
course
two-thirds of the way in it there's a
huge statement about
all the groups that you're not allowed
to um be prejudiced against in your
conduct and
and so and and so forth and so it's just
another example of how
these ideas these let's call them
anti-racist ideas for the time being
are anti-group prejudice ideas are
there there's an insistence that they
manifest themselves everywhere and you
might say well you know who isn't
anti-racist and so why object to that
and
my sense is that well
they don't come they're not part they're
not they don't stand on their own
they're part of an entire system of
ideas that's the thing that
that that's always bothered me is that
there's a whole system of ideas here
and the and i mean maybe it's best
exemplified in critical race theory
that's sort of its most extreme
experience i i also really don't believe
in seeding the language
like in saying yeah just call it
anti-racism
because i'm not seeding that language
to an ideology that is insisting on
re-segregating
the culture why why not seed the
language
because because because it's a war of
it's a war of language i mean to if
you're gonna call
what's essentially neo-racism and
neo-segregation anti-racism like
i'm not gonna go along with the lie of
that i'm just not
i am going to insist on a version of
anti-racism
that is rooted in our common humanity
and is
actually about eradicating racism
not on obsessing on the
social construct of race and reifying it
and making
us pitted in a kind of like zero-sum
war against each other based on our
immutable characteristics
i'm sorry i'm not doing that i'm not
giving in to their life yeah well then
the question is right where do you draw
the line i mean i
didn't want to use identity politics
language
in reference to personal pronouns in
canada and that's pretty much
done in my career as a as a researcher
and
probably as a clinical psychologist as
well so it's
it's not a trivial uh battle to
undertake and people of course asked
well why
did you pick that particular hill to die
on because what
weren't protections that were already
built into the law for other groups
merely extended to another deserving
group
but what i saw was a terrible misuse of
language
at a very fundamental level so part of
it was an issue of compelled speech
i have to use the terminology that you
demand and you
claim that it's only about your
emotional well-being and your identity
but
for me it's part and parcel of a
complete ideology and then there's
also the the
smuggling in of a particular view of
identity that
i don't believe has any credence
whatsoever because your identity is by
no means
only who you feel that you are your
identity is a complex
game that you negotiate with others and
it's it
what it is exactly is very difficult to
elucidate
because it's central to the nature of
human existence what your identity is
but it's certainly not
the simplistic group uh
signifier that can be that that you
conveniently hang your hat on especially
when you want to exercise arbitrary
power over other people without them
noticing that that's what you're doing
so i don't want to see the language
either and
part of the discussion we can have today
is is just about exactly what the
language implies we could talk about
systemic racism for a minute or two if
you don't mind then we'll get back to
the wall street journal story and sort
of move biographically
yeah yeah yeah well so i've been
thinking about the phrase systemic
racism
and it's a very interesting phrase
because
it's sort of systemic racism
systemic racism and you can't hear
racism
well it's important it's important you
can't hear racism like as soon as you
hear racism
there's a there's a moral issue a major
moral issue at stake
and the the proposition essentially is
if i come up to you and say this
is racist i instantly put you in a
position where if you
disagree with anything that i'm saying
you have to defend
yourself morally right to the basis of
your soul
because it's such a terrible thing
arbitrary prejudice is such a terrible
devastating thing
and virtually everyone recognizes that
and so
and so there's a club that comes along
with the use of the phrase right away
and the club is
well i'm on the right side of
history here with my claim about
opposing this terrible
satanic uh
um an ethnocentric viewpoint
and then i can say systemic and so i've
been thinking about systemic now
systemic
means pervasive it means everywhere
that's what systemic means it has
its connotations and its and its
explicit meaning
but it means that it's the central
tendency of the
system let's say and that's just wrong
the central tendency of functional
western
social institutions is not racism
the central tendency is something like
cooperative endeavor towards productive
ends
and the aberration is deception and
power and racism
but the central tendency isn't that now
and this is
this is the crucial issue here because
systemic means central tendency
and and and if you accept systemic not
only do you accept that the central
tendency is
racist let's say an exclusionary and
that also means
in support of the privilege of certain
groups because that's part and parcel of
the entire argument
but you also accept the proposition that
the motivations that
drive people to success in the
systemically racist
system also have to be power
and systemic racism hence the use of
tests like the implicit association test
so
not only are the institutions
systemically racist
but the psychological motivations of
those who are striving to move forward
within the systems
are all of a sudden now uh tyrannical
power and
systemic racism and all that's packed
into that word
systemic and it's just snuck in there
because racism is so
loud and so vicious and so horrible that
you're not allowed to object to anything
that manifests itself within its
vicinity
it's unbelievably what would you call it
well it's propagandistic is probably the
right word
but it just it blows people out of the
water because they're hit with this
racist
issue and and that just you know it
rattles them up so badly ethically that
they can't stand forward and make a
reasonable argument
well there's there's a ton there jordan
i guess i would say that
i think there is a way to acknowledge
that
for example this country had
you know in in the way that let's say
black americans were deprived of
of building generational wealth because
they were deprived of loans they weren't
allowed to buy homes
or you know redlining or jim crow or we
could go all the way back to
1619 or slavery i mean oh we could go
back a lot farther than that
but it meaning it is true that there
were systems in america
that were i don't know what other word
to say it
systemically racist well you wouldn't
you could say there
were systems in america that were racist
without saying
the resistance in america so
systemically racist there's no doubt
whatsoever
that arbitrary prejudice is a blight
upon mankind
and that it manifests itself everywhere
but it's not just arbitrary right if you
look just at one discrete example like
the drug war
the disparity between the punishment in
the 1980s between being caught with
crack and being caught with cocaine
i don't know what else to call that you
know that but i call it racist
sure but that's not just whatever the
word adjective you used before
was just before well it
this we should argue about this a lot
because it's the core point so it's a
good idea to do this
so there are definitely systematic
manifestations of racism they in
inculcate themselves let's say into the
legal system
and some of them are more explicit and
some of them are more implicit but
that's not the issue the issue
or that that's yes that's not the issue
when you're talking about
systemic racism because the there's a
tangle of claims in that term
and so please do argue with me okay so i
think
that we need to be able to acknowledge i
think as you just did
what i just said and acknow and also
see that the way that that phrase is
being weaponized right now
is basically as an argument to tear down
liberalism america and the west okay
okay so that
now okay so now we're starting to unpack
that so we're
so we'll look at the issue of racism
first
okay so people are radically
ethnocentric and that's a human
universal
now we're we have a tendency to trade
with groups of people who aren't us and
we will investigate them and explore
them but we're also
not so much terrified of them because
it's not exactly fear
but leery of them and we're leery of
them for all sorts of reasons one reason
we're leery of them i just talked to a
great biologist
whose name is going to escape me
momentarily
he formulated the parasite stress theory
of of
political belief and so one of the
things he points out is that
as isolated groups of human beings came
into contact with one another throughout
our entire evolutionary history
we were able to trade ideas and goods
and that was greatly to our benefit
but we also traded infectious agents and
that killed us a lot
and so we have this terrible tension at
the base of our being between being open
to what's new
and being killed by what's new and so
that's part of what makes us
ethnocentric it's not by any means the
entire thing so
but we have this ethnocentrism built in
as well as the desire to trade
slavery is a human universal it goes
back as far back in time as you can
as you can possibly manage and so we can
admit that all those things exist and we
can admit that their powerful tendencies
without having to
take this next step which is the one
that you pointed to by saying well
that's the
foundation of our institutions
themselves right
because of that the institutions have to
be torn down rather than saying
slavery has been with humanity for eons
and the exceptional thing about america
is not that we had slavery but that
slavery was abolished
okay and i would say that's the
exceptional thing about britain
not america because the brits did it
first and they were
that's my understanding of the situation
now that doesn't take away from the
american accomplishment
or the canadian accomplishment for that
matter right the systemic tendency is
the eradication of slavery
i'm simply saying that the thing that is
being emphasized
that i want to push back against that
often comes along with the use of the
phrase systemic racism
is the idea that because the
dead white men that created that that
that wrote the constitution or that came
up with these enlightenment values
or any number of other things that have
allowed us to
live in this exceptional let's say
civilization it's beyond just america
that because of their moral hypocrisy
that somehow
the things that they built are
ill-gotten
and need to be sort of
rooted out torn down at the core
and and i fundamentally reject that view
okay now why why should i presume that
your
fear of okay you've just characterized
the relationship between the idea of
systemic racism
with a bunch of other ideas okay so
right the idea that
there's a lot more to the story than the
mere emphasis on systemic racism there's
an uh a belief that the institutions
themselves the fundamental institutions
of the west
are corrupt right to their core
that is the implication often of the
people using the phrase but i think one
should be able to use the phrase
without implying all of that
unfortunately
right now when you hear it it tends to
be that the things i just described come
along with the use of that phrase
a little bit like anti-racism why are
you convinced
that your belief that the idea of
systemic racism is associated with these
other ideas
is true because i see it
tell me about that i mean i don't know
where to start i mean that
that is i understand that so help help
push me toward
what area you're well i i agree with you
i mean the reason that i took the stance
i took five years ago which i've had
plenty of time to think about by the way
is because i saw the linkage between
ideas i didn't believe that
this was just what it appeared to be it
was associated with an entire ideology
and the ideology seems to me to be
i'll lay out some of its features and
you can tell me if you think
it is in accord with what you see um
that inequality of outcome is evidence
of systemic discrimination
for example oh yes that would be that
inequality of outcome
conveniently described for the purposes
of just justifying the
ideology yeah let me describe how i like
some of the
the features of this ideology and you
tell me if you agree that inequality of
outcome
is necessarily a result of systemic
discrimination or systemic bigotry okay
and that's part of the equity issue
sure but again that's another one of
these words that's been hijacked
i know well that's exactly why i brought
it up is because i've been talking to a
group of people in
in in la who are liberals
and on the left of me i would say but
and
we've been stuck on this issue of equity
because i've been insisting for example
that it does mean
it's a drive towards equality of outcome
defined in exactly the manner that you
describe and their insistence is no
that's a view that only a minority of
the people
who are pushing the idea of equity hold
well the majority of people that go
along with
you know equity just think i believe in
fairness
they're not thinking deeply about this
it's like the person that says black
lives matter well of course black lives
matter
but if you look under the hood of what
the organizations
that are at the forefront of the black
lives matter movement believe well
they believe in you know abolishing the
nuclear family they believe in
abolishing or defunding the police they
believe that capitalism
is evil i mean they believe in all kinds
of things but
the majority of people that are saying
or putting up a sign black lives matter
are saying racism is bad
the majority of people that are saying i
believe in equity and diversity are
saying
i believe in the dignity of difference
and i believe in fairness and i believe
in
equality of opportunity so when the
people in these theoretical people in la
when they're saying that
is that what they mean or do they mean
something else no
they meet they well i think what they
mean is that
the people who are pushing equity
believe in equality of opportunity
and they don't see the the truth
they they're exactly right and these are
reasonable people and they're not
that they're not that happy with
political correctness i i should also
say so there is reasonable a group as i
can communicate but i have to be honest
at this point
if you can't if one can't see the way
that this language has been hijacked and
has been used as a kind of trojan horse
brilliant i should say trojan horse
strategy
to smuggle in um a sort of
hardened identity you know zero-sum
identity politics view of the world
to smuggle in a view of the world in
which we either have
collective guilt or collective innocence
literally based on the circumstances of
our birth
that smuggle in a you know deeply
anti-capitalist position
that smuggle in essentially you know a
leftist illiberalism then i'm sorry
you have blinders on i the evidence for
this is
so overwhelming at this point i'm really
not sure how
like if you if you're okay if you don't
want to believe it
i think it's because the discomfort of
believing it
outweighs the let me let me say that
again
i think it's because that admitting that
that's true
and that that's what's happening is
extremely psychologically scary
and it's extremely socially scary if you
were a liberal
because all of a sudden it means that
these institutions
and the and let's just even say like the
social world
and the culture that you took for
granted
as being a certain thing and having
certain qualities
is no longer what it appears to be and
that is the perfect segue to connect it
back to the new york times
yes okay so let's do that that that i
agree with you that let's do that now so
now you're at the wall street journal
and and you're you're starting to write
there uh yeah and
let's just fast forward that i get to
the new york times and
suffice it to say that you know i i was
never popular
um i had already published lots of
things i was known as
um being a zionist i i was known for
for you know views that put me outside
of the let's say the
the cool woke kids table and what do you
mean by you were never
popular that you just you glossed over
that very rapidly
there's an experience there there was a
skepticism
of me from the beginning but
i mean it was the new york times it's
the most important journalistic platform
in the world
and so i was more than willing to
um put up with you know getting the cold
shoulder from some of my colleagues
because the
you you just can't overstate how
powerful that distribution system is
much more so than the wall street
journal and it holds a certain
position i would say just not beyond
america you know in in
in in the west um and and so
i i was loathed to give that up and i
would be willing and was willing
to put up with a lot in order to cling
to that position well how do you think
people
saw you the like because they they they
assumed they made a variety of
assumptions about
that was what was alienating what is it
that you represented or were in their
eyes
heresy heresy someone who lived like
them went to the same restaurants as
them
dated like them um you know
by all metrics
should have agreed with them on every
tenet of this new orthodoxy
but right so you're worse because of
that see i just talked to uh
rimazar professor at mount ellison
who's who's an arab um immigrant to
canada
lebanese and she just got hung out to
drive by the
pathetic cowards at her university for
with her sin
she doesn't exactly know but apparently
it was something like incitement to
sexual violence and also insistence that
canada
isn't a systemically racist country and
and
she wrote some of this in her blog which
she thought was mostly for distribution
to her friends and
anyways uh she but she's a heretic like
you are because she's
female and she's an immigrant to canada
and so
it's incumbent upon her to adopt the
victimized identity that people like her
should
know is good for them and because she
didn't although in
quite a minor way she really literally
doesn't know what her crime was
she doesn't really know who her accusers
were they suspended her without pay
she's a tenured
professor it's a worse case than the
case
in new york with paul rossi it's much
worse it's quite stunning
i mean if you met her you'd think really
this is the
she's the person that all these
institutions was were hypothetically
designed to protect
but but if you think about it in a way
it makes sense
that it's sort of the the the people at
the edges
that are more dangerous than the people
across the street because if what your
goal is
is to reshape let's say what it means to
be liberal and progressive which is what
this is about
and if your goal is to
sort of remoralize people into that view
of the world
then you need to make examples of people
and sharpen the boundary of who's in the
community of the righteous and the good
by making examples of people who
don't go along with every part of it
because right the point of
the ostracisms and the point of what it
sounds like happen to this professor
is to say you know it's not really about
the person it's about sending a message
to everyone watching it
that if you don't fall in line if you
don't conform if you don't obey
this is what's going to happen to you
and you
you better believe that that is an
extraordinarily effective strategy
unbelievably so
so so i think what i you know what i saw
at the new york times was
i guess the only way to describe it is
is this kind of
ideological excuse me ideological
succession
and it's not just a story about the new
york times it's a story about
nature magazine it's a story about
bloomberg it's a story about harvard
it's a story about
the name the institution it's probably
about that institution
and so what's maddening
for someone who's seeing it is that for
most people on the outside
they're just saying wait it's the new
york times it has this like vested
authority it has the same font it has
the same
masthead and you're telling me that
really the new york times is no longer
the new york times and that's exactly
what i'm telling you
and it's yeah and so then the question
is what is it
well it's
well what it used to be it basically is
if the old version of the new york times
was supposed to be
you know telling the truth without fear
of favor now it's something more like
msnbc in print right if you look at fox
you look at msnbc
it's very easy to see what those things
are they're
political heroine for their side
that's increasingly what the new york
times is
and you can really point i mean you
don't have to believe
in uh you know an ideological conspiracy
to understand the um push
for that to be the new product right
go back to the age before the internet
when
the group that the new york times had to
appease were the advertisers
that was who you had to fear pissing off
well now
that advertising's basically a dead
letter who do you have to appeal to
you have to appeal to your subscribers
those are the people that are paying the
bills in the end of the day
and lo and behold 95 percent might be 92
but it's something along those lines of
new york times subscribers identify as
liberals progressives or democrats so
you better believe that in order to keep
your subscribers your readers
the people paying the bills happy you
have to give them what they want
and so we just shouldn't be surprised
anymore that fox is doing what it's
doing and that the new york times
is doing what it's doing it's very good
for business it may not be good for
democracy
but it's extremely good for business and
i think that the only reason that it's
why did it work before like if if this
is necessary
to appease your consumer base for
example i mean you made a bit of a case
there that it was the advertisers
and you said that the advertisers in
some sense now have been replaced by the
direct consumer
and they're more arbitrary um but
but it still begs the question if the
new york times was a reasonable
paper of record 20 years ago or time
magazine for that matter it's quite
shocking to look at a time magazine
from the 1970s it's about a quarter of
an inch thick and it's all text you know
it's a real magazine and that's of
course gone by the wayside
but why did it work before why was there
a market for
let's call it objective journalism five
years ago or ten years ago and there
isn't now
well social media has a tremendous
amount to do with it i mean
because there's no longer what martin
gury has called like
secret knowledge and for those who
haven't read his book the revolt of the
public it is the best
description of everything that we are
talking about
you no longer need walter cronkite or
you know or the new york times for that
matter to tell you about the
anti-semitic attack that happened in
west hollywood the other night because
by the way they're probably not going to
cover it all you need to do is follow
the right accounts on twitter
and so when information becomes
democratized
and you don't rely let's put to the side
for example
the times is excellent china coverage or
its foreign policy coverage where you
really do need an enormous budget and
people flying to the other side of the
world
oftentimes infiltrating closed societies
to tell you
what is genuinely closed information but
for
for by and large let's say on domestic
issues and a number of
and certainly style and opinion
you can just get that on the internet
and so what am i subscribing what am i
what is the reason to pay for the new
york times so the reason for that
has changed it's no longer so that you
can find out what happened in west la
the other night
increasingly increasingly first of all
it's products like
crosswords and cooking and documentaries
and all these other
things that are more like entertainment
um but it's also to
rah-rah for your team that's that's
another enormous reason for it and
i'll just add one more thing about
twitter i just you cannot overstate
the effect that social media has on
editors and reporters
you know they are people like anyone
else and you know
very well jordan as i do how bad it
feels
to get dragged and slandered on
on social media by often you know
thousands of people and you
and if you know that in advance and you
know
that writing about a certain topic or
writing about a topic that's ugly or
writing about a topic that
has a perspective that the majority of
your followers or the subscribers to
your paper don't agree with
it's like you don't need to be told
don't write about it
you tuck yourself out of it because you
don't want to experience
that punishment why is it worth it why
should i die on that hill
it's easier to commission the 5 000
op-ed
about why donald trump is is horrendous
and so every incentive just pushes you
in that direction
the social incentive both social online
but social in your real life and the
economic incentive
and frankly the incentive of the people
that you're literally surrounded by
and so resisting all of those forces is
extremely difficult
the only way that it becomes it's like
the only way it becomes possible
is if you know that the people who are
running the paper
and the people that are in charge and
the people who are in the
in the end of the day writing your
paycheck believe in that mission
that goes against those incentives and
supports you and once that falls away
and once you see as i did
that you could no longer rely on those
people to
support and sort of defend you
including against other colleagues at
the paper then
you just knew that you weren't going to
be protected anymore
okay so i want to split this now into
two i i want to continue with
am i making sense you are you were yes
absolutely
um i want to continue with the
biographical but i want to go back to
the
to the propagandistic issue too because
there's still something that we haven't
explored
so you and and i in this discussion have
fleshed out this structure of ideas
that's
lurking behind the claim of systemic
racism we haven't done that thoroughly
but we've done it to some degree we've
linked it with such things as
propagandistic
education and tried to contrast that
with the genuine exploration of ideas
but what we haven't touched on and
something that's quite mysterious to me
is
well what's driving this like what's in
it for the people who are
pushing the critical race theories well
it's
it's strange though because they're
the proposition that is being put forth
by people who hold these theories is
that it's power that's fundamentally
driving all social institutions and
that's the fundamental manifestation of
human ambition
and so but then to turn around and say
well it's power that's driving the
ideology
seems to be adopting their theoretical
stance to criticize their theoretical
stance it's like
i still don't get it like well let's
let's give them let's try and steel man
their argument right
the idea that you know for
all of human history up until five
minutes ago
that people like you were at the top of
the let's call it the caste
system and you know a black
transgender disabled person is at the
very bottom
there is an understandable impulse to
say
let's remedy that like you've had your
day in the sun jordan
so is brad pitt and you know jon hamm
and all of the other cisgendered white
males um and let's give a chance
and elevate voices who historically
let's be honest have been kept out of
the pages of the new york times
you think that 70 years ago i would have
been able to walk into the new york
times wearing a jewish star
oh i would have taken it off before i
walked in so there there is
there is a right but but you could now
except perversely and perversely you
couldn't
for any length of time because of the of
the of the
influence of the ideas that we're
describing well okay so you made a steel
man
argument there so i would i would first
say well let's take it apart carefully
all throughout history those who have
had shared some of my immutable
characteristics have had a higher
probability of attaining
uh positions of status but those
positions can't be confused only with
positions of power
because status is about much more than
power and when
systems are working properly status is
conferred upon people because they're
productive and generous and cooperative
and useful
not because they're arbitrary uh holders
of
of tyrannical power and that's so true
that it's not just true for human beings
it's also true for our nearest non-human
relatives like chimpanzees who are often
parodied as power mad but
if you do the analysis there you see
that it's reciprocity that keeps even
chimpanzee social organizations going
so there's the first thing is that it
was not merely the arbitrary
uh bestowal of power and the second
thing is is that
merely possessing those immutable
characteristics was in in no way
a certain avenue to the top because of
course throughout history
right but these these of course it
wasn't certain but the point is is that
if you didn't have those qualities you
weren't even allowed to enter the race
that's the point no i'm just trying to
understand
like what is drawing people to these
ideas okay
good-hearted well-intentioned people
and i believe that the thing that is
drawing them to these ideas is a sense
of
historical repair is a sense of
um justice
is a sense well oh fair okay fair look
fair enough
and and i mean it's not like reason i
think the reason i think it's important
to understand what's drawing people to
these ideas is because i want to defeat
these ideas
why because i believe they are
fundamentally illiberal
and because i do not believe in a world
of caste
i believe that we should be fighting for
a world in which there isn't a caste
system
not where we reverse a caste system okay
well then i would say that the
the systems that have privileged
people like me in the past are also the
same systems
for whatever reasons that have in fact
led to the freeing of the people who
weren't allowed to play the game
increasingly across time and that that's
a universal truth not a particular truth
and that
and that's the point right well and you
accept that argument
you you accept that argument and so then
then we have another problem here barry
still which is
you you're making the case that
well-meaning people want this and
i i understand your point and it's not
like i don't feel for the dispossessed
you know and and grasp the argument but
my sense is
is that the very institutions that are
under assault
by people who purport to be standing up
for the dispossessed
are in fact the best antidote to that
dispossession that the world has ever
produced
and it seems to me that if you don't see
that then you have blinders on
and if you have those blinders on then
the question is why
are you more interested in tearing down
then in building up let let me tell you
a brief story
okay and you tell me what you think of
this i had this debate with slavo zizek
and in the beginning of the debate which
it was a strange debate because he
basically declared himself not a marxist
even though that was what the debate
was about and i i say that with all due
regard for zizek who
was very kind to me when i was ill and
who seems like a fine person and so this
is not an ad hominem attack at all
people are complicated and it was a
delight actually to have the debate with
him
but in any case i started the debate
with a 15-minute critique of
of the communist manifesto and at one
point
i said it was a call to bloody violent
revolution
and the crowd cheered and laughed
for about three seconds and a
substantial
maybe ten percent of the crowd and so
there were a lot of people there who
were
on the radical end of the marxist
distribution and they had come to hear
their
purported champion you know give me a
good stomping
but it was so interesting especially for
someone who's
psychoanalytically minded because it was
a great freudian slip
i thought it put me back for about 10
seconds because i thought
really you sons of you cheered
violent bloody revolution knowing full
well what happened over the course of
the 20th century with all the
absolutely catastrophic horrors that
laid out as a consequence of marxist
ideas
because you're hidden by the crowd you
can let your laughter you can let your
resentment your desire for nothing but
upheaval manifest itself
because it's invisible but it wasn't
invisible because there were thousands
of people there
and so they laughed away about bloody
violent revolution
and so on the one hand and then i've
been talking to people i talked to
stephen blackwood this week who's
who's uh starting a a college designed
to
teach people liberal arts yeah well and
you know he insisted that people are
always pursuing the good
and i've a number of people on my show
have insisted that well that
that even if it's warped and twisted in
some it's it's an elegance to the
argument that you were making and
this isn't a criticism of you you know
you said look you can see why these
ideas are so attractive i know you are i
know you are and and i'm not going after
your argument i'm i'm just trying to
elaborate it it's
you know there there is this concern for
the dispossessed
and that's what gives the radicals the
moral high ground so often
we're concerned for the dispossessed
aren't you it's like well yes
as a matter of fact we are and so they
start out
these the the wielders of these ideas
start out with a moral advantage
yes but the evidence seems to suggest
that the very systems they're attempting
to tear down
are in fact the best antidote to the
problems that they're
laying out so then the question pops up
again so
if that's the case why the hell is there
so much force behind the ideas what's
driving it
and it's it's associated with that
laughter at the thought of violent
bloody revolution
because we're so removed from violent
that's why there's a like the l
it's a luxury to flirt with these ideas
it's that's a good that's a really good
that's a really good idea
if you think if you are so
if you take the fact let's just take an
example
that i can you know i'm not wearing long
sleeves you could see my collarbone
and that i can walk down the street here
with my wife and go get a
falafel at the end of the street and not
be stoned to death
okay like that's the reality that's a
miracle
that's right and that's what divides
people is whether or not they know
that's a miracle
yes and if you are so removed from the
truth
of that miracle and from gratitude
for everyone and every idea every piece
of scaffolding that allows for that to
be that my reality
then you will have the foolishness
but it's really the luxury and the
decadence to flirt with
ideas about doing away with it and i
just i don't know
why some people feel like okay i'm going
to steal
i'm going to steal men i was going to
say one thing
okay i am so curious about
why certain people feel in their bones
how thin the veneer of civilization is
and why other people are so nonchalant
about it
i feel it's a psychological question but
i don't know it
i don't know either i don't know either
you know when i was in graduate school i
was obsessed with the finitude of life
and with mortality and death i mean i
wake up every morning and think
there's no time get to it now and i had
friends
who i would say were more well adjusted
than me that's certainly part of it like
they were more emotionally stable
technically speaking
less prone to depression and anxiety so
that's part of it
and they it was that those ideas never
entered the theater of their imagination
right it did they they just weren't a
set of existential problems for them
for me it's always been paramount and i
very
i read oh
i can't he worked for the new york times
too a great journalist he wrote of
but i can't remember the book anyways he
had spent a lot of time in beirut
during the catastrophes in beirut and
then he talked about going to a baseball
game in the united states
right and he he was at this baseball
game with all these people who were
sitting there
doing what people do at baseball games
chat nonchalantly drink a bit of beer
have a hot dog it's like
i went to a i've hardly gone to any
baseball games and i went to one in
boston and
i was thinking jesus this is boring
nothing's happening why are people here
don't they have something better to do
and then i started to look around and i
thought
oh i see i'm so wrong
they're here because this is nothing to
do
it's just leisure it's like you don't
really have to pay it
but it's deeper it's channeling those
human forces that want us to go into
tribal warfare
and putting it you know into supporting
the red sox or the yankees
right right which is a miracle yes
there's that's exactly but the whole
thing is a miracle is that we can go out
there
and play out these tribal antagonisms at
a completely peaceful level
and sit there and and and and and have
it be
benevolent and calm and then i realized
well people do this for leisure that's
why they're doing this
and you're the idiot not them but but
the the the commentator the author
he had a hard time going to baseball
games after he had been in beirut
because
the thinness of the veneer was always
apparent to him after that
because he couldn't drive across the
city without being stopped by armed
gangs constantly and
i guess it's also maybe to some degree
whether your view of humanity
tilts more towards hobbs or more towards
rousseau
you know and i like to think of myself
as balance between the two because i
think people
do do do have the capacity for good and
that you know it's not a war against
all um in the state of nature but i
certainly
am sensitive to the state of nature
argument it is always a miracle to me
when i go outside and there isn't a riot
in the streets
and i do think it's a thin veneer and we
have to be very careful with it
so dostoevsky said in notes from the
underground
one of the most insightful passages
there
sections he talks about the flaws in
utopian think thinking he said well
people are constituted such that if you
provided them with utopia
the first thing they would do is break
it to pieces
just so that something interesting would
happen so that they could have their own
capricious way
and that's very much akin to the
argument that you're making the luxury
argument
and so then there's a there's another
problem there that we could delve into
that i
i've talked about with the sort of
rational optimist types like matt ridley
and bjorn lomberg and so on is that
we offer young people this luxury that
produces the kind of decadence that
you're describing
but what they're deprived of is the
opportunity for romantic adventure
and so part of the positive thing that's
driving them to shatter the veneer
is the desire for something more than
you know the cause
yeah yes yes it's a yes i i
i completely agree with you
yeah it's a desire for it's a
disadventure
for meaning yeah meaning and you know
this is something we could talk about
this for a long time but i think that
there is a reckoning that
that needs to be had with you know the
new atheists or what was called the new
atheists in a group
i've been so why do you say that
well only because one
well let me back up into it this way
when i look at the qualities
of the people who have the strength
and the fortitude to not go along with
the crowd
and to be willing to be slandered and to
sacrifice for the sake of resisting this
illiberalism
almost all of them are religious in some
way or another
almost all of them were deeply deeply
anchored i would say to
i don't want to say spirituality but
like local
something deeper is rooting them that's
what solzhenitsyn said against the
about the people he met in the gulag who
could who could stand up to the
to the to the soviets and i think that's
the thing i'm finding again and again
now as i'm sort of making my way through
all of these different sectors of life
reporting on the spread of this ideology
who's willing to talk to me who's
willing to speak up um
and one of the things that i
don't necessarily think that that the
atheist group
you know who i admire on a lot of levels
that they maybe couldn't have foreseen
is that robbing people of that religious
impulse
both sort of soften the ground for the
rise of this
deeply liberal ideology that functions
in many ways
like a new religion and also ham
like it just deprived it in a way it's
deeply
connected i think to the rise of this
new orthodoxy
so i've been thinking about the idea of
of
rendering unto caesar what is caesar's
and rendering unto god what is god's and
it seems to me that if we blur the
distinction between
god and caesar then caesar becomes god
it's not that we dispense with god
that's the thing and that's that's
what's
at the core that's what's wrong with the
new atheist hypothesis is that
so imagine just psychologically that we
have a drive towards ethical unity
and that would be the same force that
drives us towards a monotheism right the
idea that all is one is that there has
to be a unifying
spirit that animates and unites all of
our ethical strivings and
and we picture that in all sorts of
different ways but it tilts in this
monotheistic direction and so
that becomes a transcendent value and
it's the value the transcendent value
from which we derive our notions of
sovereignty and individual worth and
natural law and all of that but it's a
psych
it's a psychological necessity i would
say that rises
from the requirement that we
build our ethical systems in a manner
that's internally non-contradictory
because that drives them towards a unity
well and then we have to worship that
unity or we worship something else that
approximates it and that would be one of
these totalizing systems that
you know that you discussed where
instead of there being god who's
mysterious and who we can't understand
and who we have some relationship with
that we can't specify
and whom we have to struggle with
because that's the meaning of the term
israel right to struggle with god
we replace it with a an idol we replace
it with an idol that has exactly the
same totalizing impulse but
lacks all the advantages of that of that
transcendent that
can't be identified with us that's the
thing is that
you know if stalin doesn't have god then
stalin is god
and that's not that's and that seems to
me to be somewhat independent of whether
or not there is a god
which is that's a different issue right
the metaphysical reality of that unity
is a different issue than the
psychological necessity of that unity
and i do think the new atheists i mean
they're getting hoist on their own
petard to some degree you see what's
happened to dawkins in the last
couple of months strip strip of his
award by the humanist because he dared
to challenge this rising
religious orthodoxy and i do think it is
that
and so now i want to switch a little bit
here so
and talk about your column you talked
about you just showed it to me but i had
to come across it before
it's a call to what people need to do in
order to resist
this totalizing um
propaganda let's call it and we've
started to explore the reasons for its
existence
now the reason i want to bring it up is
because
we've also been making the case that we
people do
need something like a romantic adventure
and and toying with catastrophe
at the fringes provides that romantic
adventure right because you're joisting
jousting with the dragon at that edge
you can understand if you have any sense
if you can remember what it was like to
be a teenager at all
you can you can understand how exciting
it would be yes well that's for sure and
confusing
but you could also understand how it's
exciting to go to a riot
and then to sit and drink a few beer
afterwards and to talk about
the incredible excitement that that
generated and especially if that's
bolstered by your sense that you're on
the moral frontier
now you have had an adventure
and your adventure at least in principle
was a consequence of telling the truth
and that to me is the replacement for
that romantic adventure is that
if you embody the truth in your own life
you have that romantic adventure
and the thing you straighten out is you
not other people
so you don't get to have an enemy under
those conditions
and so you have a call in your column
too and
i explored this as well with paul rossi
who stood up against
you know the the incursion of the
politically correct agenda into his
classrooms
so let's go back to the new york times
now you're trying to
i presume you're trying to explore the
truth to tell the truth what are you
doing as a journalist
i mean all kinds of things i would say
the thing that that
got me the most national attention in
the beginning were
some columns that i wrote that i think
subsequently have definitely become the
commonsensical position the the most
on me too so the the biggest one was
this piece that i wrote about aziz
ansari and i wrote a piece about
called the limits of believe all women
it was basically saying
you know we should just never
but it's trust but verify and that
someone's
gender shouldn't determine whether or
not what they're saying is true it
seemed to me a very basic
point but uh it caused a lot of
controversy and
you know but i did lots of different
pieces i did pieces i wrote that piece
about the intellectual dark web of
course
i did deep features you know like one on
the city of david which is the most
important archaeological dig
in in jerusalem that tells us a lot
about what jerusalem used to be and says
a lot about its future
all kinds of stories but the thing that
i love doing more than
more than writing was commissioning
pieces that other people didn't agree
with
um and working with writers i mean
there's nothing that i love more than
commissioning and editing and that's
still the case and i'm doing a lot of
that why
why why do you love that what is it
about it when it's working right
helping someone first of all the excite
like if you've never published before
and then you get to be read by people in
the world like go back
in your mind if you can to the first
time that that happens
that happened for you maybe in your own
life it's extremely
exciting the experience of that and
getting to engage why do you think why
do you think that's so exciting
and you're making the case that you were
opening up that avenue of opportunity to
other people
well i was okay so i wanted i want to
comment on
well i want to comment on that a little
bit briefly and then go back to
well let me just say this one thing here
because
yeah i was going to give you i was going
to give you an example of do
i interviewed someone um i was
there there were kind of panels of
people that would interview new hires
and i was brought in
as i always was as the kind of
intellectual diversity person
and it really struck me because the
first thing that this candidate
to be an op-ed editor the first thing
she said to me was
i don't know how you can edit op-eds
from people you disagree with
and i said that's kind of the point of
the job here
and it's fun because it not only for the
pleasures the personal pleasures of
helping someone find their voice and
articulate
what they want to say in the in the most
clear and
powerful way possible but why is that a
pleasure
why is that a pleasure i don't know why
it's like going for a swim in the
sunshine
no no this is more this is a more
crucial point i'll tell you why
because one of i've been thinking very
hard about this proposition that our
social institutions are predicated on
power
and power implies aggressive
exploitation that implies forcing people
to do things that are against their will
and the the proposition that our
social institutions are predicated on
power implies that there is
pleasure substantial pleasure in forcing
people to do things that they wouldn't
otherwise do against their will
now what i've seen instead in the
functional institutions that i've been
associated
with is that the best people are
fundamentally motivated by
exactly what you just said and that's
why i'm holding in on it which is that
there's something unbelievably
intrinsically pleasurable and now you
said about
helping people find their voice and
expressing themselves in the clearest
possible terms
and that doesn't matter whether you
agree with them or not and you love
that and that's to see yes yes
well that is the opposite of power it's
not just that
it isn't that power manifests itself in
these institutions it's that when
they're
running properly it's the very opposite
of power it's the
opening up of the possibility of
creative expression for others
and we take tremendous pleasure in that
i don't think there's a more fundamental
human pleasure than that
a deeper more fundamental pleasure
yeah and then you think you think so oh
it's so odd because you you focused on
this anecdote
how can you do that even for people that
you disagree with
well it turns out that the pleasure of
opening up the possibility of expressing
the ideas the thoughts the pleasure in
that is so intense that
you'll even take the hit to your own
beliefs in order to engage in it
and it also there's a selfish aspect of
it too which is that it sharpens your
own beliefs
it sharpens them to encounter and
actually to help someone with the
opposite beliefs
articulate them in the most powerful way
possible forces you
to confront your own and i think that
i take a lot of pleasure in that i mean
it's it's the kind of pleasure of like
going for a run you know it's maybe not
like
an immediate it's it's it's different
than than licking an ice cream cone
but it's a deeper kind of pleasure in a
way
um and i thought well i think that that
was the game it's the same
that would be allied with the same
motivation because imagine that
if part of what's giving you pleasure is
the ability to foster the
um the capacity of other people to
communicate to formulate their ideas and
communicate
while you're doing that you're also
fostering that within yourself by
you know putting yourself to the test
constantly well it's a it's a repetition
of the same fundamental motivation
and so it seems to me that when when our
social institutions are functioning
properly
then the basis of the relationship
between individuals within it
at different levels of the hierarchy is
actually one of
broadened it's more like parenthood than
it is like the expression of power
well what i'm expressing though is like
so old-fashioned
like they you know it's not necessarily
a gener it's largely a generational
divide it doesn't always break down
along those lines but i would say
for the younger generation of people who
don't believe let's say in journalism as
embodying the values i just described
exploratory
and hearing the other perspective and
trying in fact to make it as strong as
it possibly can be
hearing the other person in good faith
all of those things that are like
fundamental to the liberal world view
they don't believe that they believe in
journalism as a tool
and why why do they believe that now is
that a consequence
of their education yeah it's completely
connected to the ideas that i was
describing encountering when i was a
student at columbia or that young me
park described to you
you know it turns out that the there was
an idea until extremely recently
that was shared by conservatives and
liberals in your generation i would say
that what happened on largely what
happens on campus days on campus
the oberlin gender studies major will
make her way into the universe and
she'll get her job at mckinsey
and she's going to leave those silly
ideas behind no no
that is not what's happened it turns out
ideas really really matter
ideas are extremely serious and if
you're marinating
at the most important formative years of
your life
in basically an echo chamber of
this ideology and then all of a sudden
you're going into these institutions
incredibly important institutions
that are our newspapers our publishing
houses
are hollywood like go go down the line
it's not like you're leaving checking
those ideas at the door you're bringing
them with you
and what we've seen is that you don't
actually need a majority of people
inside an institution to agree with
these ideas
for these ideas to gain moral for these
ideas to gain force
no you need a tiny minority a tiny
minority and you need cowardice at the
top
cowardice at the top that is the key
ingredient
you need people at the top who are
willing to sell out
the authority of the institution and the
values of the institution that have
taken
decades sometimes centuries to accrue
basically for the short-term benefit
of not being called a bad name
okay so let's delve into that a little
bit okay because that's actually pretty
bloody
awful as it turns out you know i mean we
don't want to
and look here's what i've learned in the
last five years one thing i've learned
is that most people will
shut up very rapidly and apologize when
attacked and a very small minority won't
why is that well because it's because
it's so horrible to be attacked and not
only that
because it's so horrible to be attacked
but also because
if you're a sensible person and you get
attacked
the right thing to think to begin with
is maybe stupid and wrong
yes exactly of course exactly natural
well it's not only natural it's even
been it's beneficial right i mean
because you want to be reactive to your
social surround
and so then the question becomes well
the first question is
why stick your neck out at all when the
cost of sticking your neck out is
like extraordinarily high
psychologically and practically which
it's certain even if you stick your neck
out accidentally
which so because it's never
i guess because i think because it's
because there are things that are and i
i don't know how to say this without
sounding cheesy
but like there are virtues that are
so much more important than getting
ratioed on twitter
there just are there again without
sounding too
like high-minded if you can get in touch
with things that are
that you're willing to risk your life
for or let's say risk your reputation
for
it's only then will you be able to
withstand the pain
of the lies and the slander
okay so what are you gonna what do you
what
you gave up your job at the new york
times i'm going to return to this point
you just
i want to run through the biography
again now you're working at the new york
times you're not the world's most
popular person there no
so you're you're paying a price now you
can obviously tolerate that
you're constitutionally built so that
you can tolerate that
i think that i i i'm not an expert in
this subject but i think that i would
qualify as highly disagreeable
yes according to your definition
although it's hard for me to say that
because i
really care what other people think
about me yeah well you might be low
higher
you should take my personality test and
find out because i suspect you
i suspect you're low in politeness and
high in compassion
that splits that splits agreeableness
say because then you would care for
other people
but you'd still be willing to say what
you
have to say i suspect that's and i also
suspect you're probably pretty high in
conscientiousness and openness
and that makes you a weird political
animal because openness tilts you in the
liberal direction
but conscientiousness tilts you in a
conservative direction
but it'd be worth taking the test to
find out i'll take it i've never taken
it i
okay in general i'd never take
personality i don't know what my myers
bring is either but i will take it
i guess it's a longer conversation but
the question of
how to incentivize
like i'm obsessed with the idea of
courage and what makes people
courageous or what makes people willing
to
be natan sharansky or be andrei sakharov
like
what is it i think it's fear of god
yeah you know they say that's the
beginning of wisdom well i kind of i
mean that
i i mean that genuine genuinely but also
metaphorically
a lot of courage i think is being afraid
of the right thing
like i don't think it was courage that
drove me to to do what i did five years
ago in canada i think it was fear of
what was coming
as an alternative i could see it it was
like well there's a little beast here
that i could tackle
or there's a great huge beast that's
lumbering forward in the distance
but why are so many people deluding
themselves
into thinking that if they just like
keep quiet about
any number of the issues we're talking
about that it will somehow get easier
to speak out later like
this is going to be the easiest time
right now yeah well that's the thing i
don't i don't know how
i don't know what the conditions are for
learning that you see that's one thing
i kind of i think i've sort of known
that
for a long long time that the the time
to have the fight
is now for me i think
being deeply connected
to jewish history and feeling like
it's not just history but it's like
a compass in my life and that
i am deeply obligated to
its lessons and deeply obligated
to all of the people who suffered and
sacrificed so that i can live in the
freedom
and the privilege that i have like
that's my anchoring thing and
it just i'm interested in how do we
incentivize more people to see what this
is and to sort of come out of the closet
because
the thing that is like so fascinating to
me about this this
strange phenomenon is like by any
measure we're living in
the freest societies that human beings
have ever known
and they're rapidly improving yes and
that people are
acting as if and for very understandable
reasons
like we're living in a totalitarian
society to some degree
meaning they are double thinking they
are living
lives in which they have a private
persona
and they will tell me in private at
dinner totally agree with you
but i could never say it out loud like
that phenomenon to me is
so unbelievably widespread and
yeah well that's that's the state well
that is the that is the indication of
the dawning of the totalitarian state
because
the totalitarian state depends entirely
on the dissociation between the public
persona and the private viewpoint and
to the degree that each person is
willing to swallow that lie
that's their contribution to the
totalitarian state
and so it is a requirement it's
interesting that you you know you
pose your moral obligation in terms of
your responsibility
to at least in part to jewish history
one and
and the fact that so many times people
didn't say what they needed to say and
the consequences were absolutely
catastrophic
i mean that's certainly the case in nazi
germany
to say the least but it also
characterized the style
the stalinists and the maoists and all
of those totalitarian states
i mean if people people need to realize
that if
they're in a position where they can't
say what they think that that's
the evidence that we're sliding in a
direction that's not good it's
there's the evidence it's right there
and what do you do about that well you
say
what you think carefully and the reason
for that is the uh
the alternative is worse that's that's
the
i also think that
it was really hard for me to
give up the prestige of working god i
bet that i wanted yeah i want to hear
about it it was really hard for me and
but i think that like
putting myself like i have the fact that
i had
already put myself on the hook so
publicly
for standing up for certain values made
it impossible for me not to follow
through with doing the right thing
it's a little bit like when i wanted to
run the marathon like i
insanely because i can't run a half a
mile right now but years ago i ran the
new york city marathon having never been
a runner in my life and the way that i
did that was i told everyone in my life
i'm running a marathon before i'd even
run a step
and the pressure to sort of follow
through
with what i had publicly stated was very
good
because it forced me to do it and i
guess what i would say to
nietzsche said every great man is the
actor of his own ideal
well yeah i guess what i would say to
people listening to this is
like put yourself on the hook now in
front of people that you respect and
admire
and maybe even do it in a public way
because then when the testing time comes
it's very embarrassing not to follow
through with with
living by your ideals well and let's say
well the testing time isn't going to
come and we're just overstating the
danger
because that's that that's the rationale
right that's the nationals
well do you think we're overstating it
we could talk about france
well i i don't know i don't know right
because who knows right i don't know
which way history is going to turn it
it doesn't look very i'm i'm certainly
not happy with what's happening in the
universities i'm not happy with what's
happening in the scientific journals
it doesn't seem to me a great thing that
diversity inclusivity and equity is
popping up
absolutely everywhere that human
resources departments have a
stranglehold on corporations
all i'm saying is that if we're living
in a world
in which people cannot say their
commonsensical views
out loud okay i'm not talking about
political views i'm talking about
are there differences between men and
women are
you know is is america fundamentally
a good place is lincoln a hero
like these are basic things that have
become
taboo if we cannot say those basic
things out loud and if those
ideas about the fundamental goodness
let's say of the american project but
really of the western project
have become really of i would say more
than that i would say of humanity itself
because okay
this is a fundamental critique the idea
that our social institutions are
predicated on exploitative power
that's not that's a critique of the
human spirit sure it goes past even the
west
yeah if you can't say that looting is
bad
okay to think about this summer if you
can't say that
segregation is evil and wrong
if you can't say that i mean we all know
what the things are
the things that have become unsavable
and i'm suggesting that
that is enough for me to sound the alarm
and if it turns out that i was a little
paranoid or hysterical
but i made these things more sayable
in in sounding the alarm i'm okay with
that
i'd rather be wrong now
so tell me tell me you
why did what happened when you decided
to leave the times
well i mean how did you come to i'd like
the story what how did you come to that
decision
well there was a kind of
forced ideological conformity
that was happening and it became
like a battle to get any piece through
that didn't conform to the narrative
and anything that didn't how would that
battle manifest itself so you would
commission
all stories in all kinds of ways yeah i
mean it would be
i'd like to do a column on this and
me being tremendously ch like having to
jump through hoops
and get 10 more sources whereas other
pieces from other writers would just
sail through with like obvious
embarrassing errors
um not that i haven't had my own share
of errors i have and they're
horrifically embarrassing and anyone can
find them online
but i'm saying if you didn't
comport with the orthodoxy then you
your character and your work were just
unbelievably scrutinized
in a way that another person's weren't
when it came to so the load increased
the effort
yeah i mean when it came to
commissioning things like i'm
you know i i remember ion her cle called
me the smuggler because early on when i
was there again in this very brief
good period of self-reflection i was
able to get an op-ed that she wrote
into the new york times and she was like
i can't believe you were able to do that
so there was this brief period in the
beginning where
the humiliation of getting trump wrong i
think
led to an opening of the overton window
but then for reasons i can't really
figure out it really really really just
closed again and it
narrowed much more so like to a sliver
in a way it was much narrower than i
would say pre the election
and of course trump had a tremendous
amount to do with it
if you believed that you know and i
think a lot of my colleagues genuinely
believed this that
trump was a fundamental threat to
america to the republic
to minorities we can go on and on and on
we know the argument we could read it
anywhere else um then you were morally
obligated
defeat that threat and that meant that
anything that flirted with any number of
topics
where he was on the a particular side of
it then
the right was all that like the correct
position
was always to be on the opposite side of
it and so you saw this
really really clearly let's say in the
in the lab leak theory
right which was completely of of the
wuhan of uh coronavirus
um which increasingly it seems like the
coronavirus was
you know unintentionally let's say
leaked from this lab in wuhan well that
became unsayable
and it became unsayable because people
in the trump administration were saying
that that was the case
and so everything was seen through the
prism of
this incredibly singular figure of trump
so
that sped it all up and then you had
the summer and you had the killing of
george floyd and that just
brought every thing that was sort of at
a low boil
just absolutely bubbling over and the
way that it bubbled over
most acutely was in the choice in june
to run an op-ed by republican senator
tom cotton
that said not that the national guard
should be brought in to quell peaceful
protests
but that the national guard should be
brought in brought into quell violet
rioting it was a controversial piece
um by any stretch in that really
sensitive moment but it was a view
frankly that was shared by the majority
of americans if you go back and look at
polls
at that time but inside the context the
rarified context of the new york times
not only was this op-ed seen as
controversial it was seen as
literal violence literal violence
800 more than 800 of my colleagues
signed a letter
saying that this op-ed literally put the
lives of black new york times staffers
in danger
and anyone that knows what was no
argument what kind of argument was made
in favor of that position
that the argument was first of all it
was a misreading of his op-ed
it was based on a fundamental misreading
that insisted
that his op-ed was about bringing in the
military to put down
justified understandable riots in
reaction to george floyd so they never
made the distinction they collapsed the
distinction between
bringing in the national guard to put
down violent rioting and bringing in the
national guard to put down peaceful
protests
and then they said you know that that
because police and the military are
systemically racist i'm being crude and
just
giving you the overview that this move
would necessarily result in inordinate
amount of black death
the death of black americans so that was
the so just
that was the argument and what happened
was not from the top a defense of the
op-ed
and a defense of all of the various was
this an op-ed you had commissioned
no i had nothing to do with it okay okay
so you're just watching this
yeah i ended up being sort of
brought in uh as a kind of punching bag
because
i ended up tweeting out some tweets that
i think hold up extremely well
about that this was a very very useful
litmus test to understand the
generational divide
inside the new york times but i had
nothing to do with the op-ed but the
people that
did have something to do with the op-ed
my 25-year old
uh-huh i want to ask you something about
that generational divide sorry
it's okay well i'm still trying to think
through this
the the the education of young people
to adopt the viewpoint that our social
institutions are fundamentally corrupt
and driven by
power so then i think well
how much of that this calls for
speculation
how much of that is a consequence of the
breakdown of family structure i mean
so i see the the positive element of our
social
institutions as something like the
positive aspect of
of the paternal spirit so it's a father
it's the positive father who encourages
in exactly the way that you encourage
the writers that were under your care to
express themselves and develop
am i the father in that situation well
you would be well you know you're
female but you're working in the
patriarchy so yes that's a
i would say symbolically speaking that
that's a manifestation of
well the spirit of your jewish ancestors
let's put it that way well i mean that i
mean that
you know uh and and you're the one who
said that that tradition has shaped you
to such a degree it's like while you're
in body you feel you have an obligation
to embody that well
is it not a paternal spirit that's the
tradition
and it's the but what if you've never
experienced that i don't know if i would
call it paternal or not
that's not the way i think about things
but i
i do think i don't know if your family's
broken if you've never had a positive
relationship with someone who's
i think it's different than that i think
it's about
should corporations which is what the
new york times is in the end of the day
should they be moral actors that's the
big difference like
there's a sense among the younger
generation
that a newspaper or a tech company
or or whatever the the place that you
work
should somehow also not just be about
pursuing the bottom line but should also
be a manifestation
of what you consider to be good politics
and good morals
and that's why you see you know i don't
know if you followed this entire story
at coinbase that i think is really
really interesting where basically
the heads of coinbase said because they
felt like rather than
pursuing excellence for the company so
much of employees
energy and attention and time was being
devoted to
you know using slack to discuss the
politics of the day and they basically
said look
no more politics at work that's not work
is not a place for politics
work is a place for making coinbase
excellent and if you're uncomfortable
with that
we're going to give you a really really
nice severance package you've seen base
camp follow suit
you've seen and i i suspect that when
did this happen
this happened um i would say coinbase in
the past two
months and then base camp another silic
another company
much more recently and
this i i'm really watching that trend
because
if you're running a company and
rather than let's take the case of the
new york times you're spending you're
not spending your time
reporting and editing and commissioning
but you're spending your time basically
being like an offense
archaeologist looking through things
that other people have published
to decide whether or not an adjective
was orientalist or not
like that's a bad use of your time
if you are supposed to be producing the
best newspaper in the world and so
that's one thing i'm watching for i'm
curious if what coinbase did
is gonna take off um because i think
it's extremely
i thought that was just really really
really smart strategy to say
no that's not gonna be that's not gonna
be what we do with this company but
suffice it to say the new york times has
not followed coinbase's suit
and what happened after so
the fallout from the tom cotton episode
was that
within 48 hours my immediate boss was
reassigned
my the boss who had hired me james
bennett
was pushed out of the paper after he was
struggle sessioned in front of thousands
of employees at the company
in tell us about that i will well in
slack channels with thousands of people
guillotines and axe emojis were put next
to his name and my name
um and no one said a word about that
remember this is an ideology that tells
us silence is violence
you know and and you know guillotine
guillotine
emojis aren't exactly but basically what
happened was that you know
they it's the same script that's
happened everywhere else
like a normal human being who looked out
and saw that 800 of his colleagues
felt that he decided to run an op-ed
that literally put their lives in danger
well the normal human response to that
as you explained before is
i'm so sorry but unfortunately in the
rubric of this ideology
i'm so sorry is evidence of your guilt
it's blood in the water and that's
exactly what happened i mean it was
i'm so sorry it's a confession yes
confession
and yes which means don't apologize if
you haven't done anything wrong
yes because that's exactly right and so
he was pushed out of the paper
and perhaps most disgustingly um
my colleague is a very dear friend of
mine adam rubinstein who was one of the
editors one of seven editors who worked
on the piece
his name was leaked by others of our
colleagues to the new side of the paper
and a 25 year old editor at the very
beginning of his career
was sort of the the guy that was thrown
under the bus and he ultimately ended up
leaving the paper too
and i found that to be the most
disgusting part of the entire episode
because
as everyone who works in any
organization knows um
and he didn't make him there was no
mistake that was in that op-ed
but generally what happens in a
collegial environment is if someone
makes a mistake so for example
months prior to the tom cotton episode
the new york times ran a flagrantly
anti-semitic cartoon
in which um bibi netanyahu the prime
minister of israel
is shown wearing a it's shown as a
as a dachshund a long wiener dog
wearing a um a collar with a jewish star
and he's shown leading
a blind trump who's wearing a yamacon
his head people can look it up
now everyone in the editorial staff knew
who chose that op-ed
sorry that that cartoon and no one in
the public knows his name
and that's exactly as it should be it's
exactly as it should be
and yet in this case a 25 year old
editor was hung out to dry
so essentially what i gathered from this
entire episode was
risk-taking can get you fired
running an op-ed that other people
inside the paper considered
controversial
could get you struggle session in front
of the entire company
and knowing that that was literally what
my job was
well that job became impossible and
the thing that happened that i it's
really unbelievable if you're thinking
about like running a large
organization this will sound as insane
as it is
the the new rule became kind of editing
by consensus
so every single op-ed editor had to say
that they were comfortable with
every single op-ed well you can imagine
that if 9.9 out of people
uh 9.9 out of 10 people agree with this
view of the world that my job became
impossible by the time that i
you know sort of the last few weeks of
the paper i was told explicitly don't
commission op-eds anymore
because they're none of them are i mean
none of them were able to get through
this new gauntlet
and i said to myself you know why did i
go into journalism
i i did not go into journalism to be
rich
you know i went into journalism because
it's it's a it's a job that lets you
that allows you to pursue your curiosity
which is unbelie which is incredible and
if i can't do that anymore
and if i need to sort of like become a
half version of myself
and sit on my hands about an increasing
number of topics that i think are
incredibly urgent
what's the point of doing this and so
i felt like you know i could kind of
like become a husk or i could leave of
my own volition
before something similar happened to me
and
so i decided to leave and left in a very
public way and
i'm having no idea sort of what i would
do next and i will be honest it took me
a long time to sort of like
get my bearing after i did that have you
got your baby
and in retrospect i would say to anyone
considering leaving an institution
have a good plan in place for what you
plan to do next
because i wish that's no easy thing to
manage i mean it's
you know you you had well a dream job
fundamentally right i mean that's the
pinnacle to be an op-ed editor at the
new york times that's
that's that's a star position have i
thought
yeah have i gotten my bearing my
bearings
i i would say very much so and i feel
well good for you
i feel so much more optimistic now than
i did you know if i left in july it was
in august and september i mean it was
very
disorienting at first to feel like wow
i've been in institutions for my entire
life
i've never been an entrepreneur i've
never i've never
had to figure out all these things for
myself
you know i've always sort of been in
these fancy institutions and what would
it look like to try and build one myself
and how would i and this is something
i'm struggling with a lot right now or
not struggle struggling in a good way
how do i resist the same forces
that i so criticize the new york times
for and let me give you a specific
example so i'm writing on sub stack now
and it's incredible
tell us about sub stack too so so sub
stack for people that don't know is this
new platform
for well it's for any writers um
but that allows people to subscribe
directly to you
and so i publish about two things a week
often a column that i've written in a
column i've commissioned but ultimately
i want to build this into a much bigger
media company but this is the start of
it and it's going extremely extremely
well and
i'm in the top 10 of you know politics
so
i just have to go a little bit further
to beat you know andrew sullivan and
glenn greenwald
um so it's going really well but the
thing that is
um corrupting about it it's the same
force that's corrupting at the new york
times or any media right
now which is to say i know that if i run
certain kinds of stories that that's
going to be like a heroin hit for my
readers
and i see you see right away yes and we
all know about the temptation of
providing heroin hits for our readers
yes and it's very
i mean and at least at the new york
times you have some insulation
okay you write one column that is a
viral hit great you write
one the next month that's only a couple
hundred thousand
but there is some level of insulation
with substack there's none
i see every single night how many people
are
converting to paid subscriptions and i
see extremely clearly
what kinds of stories make make that
happen
and i don't want to give in to the same
i don't want to radicalize my readers in
a certain direction
and so you have to be as an editor and
as a writer disciplined
you know i'm going to commission this
story you have to be pursuing something
else eh
that's the thing is i mean i've
struggled with the same thing with
with this podcast i mean and what i'm
trying to do
maybe this is insulation i i don't know
as i'm trying to learn
things i don't know and so i'm talking
to people that i think are interesting
and i'm hoping they'll teach me
things so that i'm not quite so stupid
and if people
are happy with that i mean i i read the
comments i'm
responsive to my audience i respect my
audience but
the respect is that i'm going to take
them along for the journey
that and so i'm not tailoring it to an
audience at all
and that's it but what's so nice about
that is it really seems to work like
when i'm not tailoring to my audience
when i'm engaging in a genuine
conversation that's when the responses
are the best
and so that's so heartening that that's
the case i mean what are you seeing with
regards to
responses what what's the temptation
exactly
yeah so i think that you know when i
resigned from the new york times
that letter i think was probably the
most widely read thing that i've ever
written
and i'm really really proud of it but i
think in a way i became like symbolic of
let's just say like the anti-woke
position and
on the one hand i think it's extremely
important for me to report on that and
i'm
really proud of the reporting that i've
done exposing the way that this ideology
for example is taking over k-12
education
and one of the reasons i think it's so
important that i do it is that the
mainstream media is not going to touch
it
because it's the same ideological
succession that they're implicated in
so on the one hand i think i have a
particular burden
to write about this topic that's being
untouched and on the other hand
i don't want every single piece to be
pounding the drum beat yeah
yeah one of the problems because because
then it's a feeling of like
oh my god the world's melting down it's
like no you also want to give people
a sense of perspective so that's that's
my challenge but i imagine for other
writers on the site it's a different
challenge and
yeah the challenge is that you don't
want to become a parody of yourself
and serve your your previous image i
mean that's a very
that's a very troublesome thing
especially as your image
develops so as you said you've become
symbolic of something
and so then the question is is the power
of that symbol so overwhelming that it
shapes your entire character and
everything that you do
and there's there's there's definite
incentives in that direction
but and it's hard to resist and it's
being demanded in some sense by your
audience
right so right and it's it's really hard
also because
i i picture my reader as someone who
still reads the new york times in the
washington post and they're coming to me
for the thing they're not getting there
but for the readers who are
only reading me let's say and only
reading a handful of writers that are
sort of playing in my same playground
that can have a radicalizing effect and
so
i just want to that's the thing right
and it's because you're also not
embedded with a bunch of other opinions
as you would be in the newspaper right
exactly
so that's right and so my dream
situation
and what i'm trying to build toward is
creating that ecosystem
i'm not interested in
like the creator economy
whatever that meaning i think i've
watched you
and i've watched other public figures
who have become
such potent symbols and on the one hand
i'm like
look at the effect that they've had it's
so powerful
and i know just from what when i was you
know writing about the intellectual dark
rabbit webb and reading 12 rules for
life
i remember sitting at a hotel and a
young waiter a man coming up to me
saying like that book saved my life
and that's unbelievably powerful and on
the other hand
it's the burdens of it seem very
scary and dangerous to me and so yeah i
want to place myself
ideally in a in a kind of
round table like a kind of group where
where it's like a sensibility
and i'm not the only one because
i don't know am i wrong about no no i
don't think you're wrong at all i mean
in this
in the new book i wrote beyond order i
talk about
this necessity for social interaction as
a as a
sanity as the prime sanity maintaining
uh process is that sane people aren't
saying because they're so
organized internally that their psyches
are organized properly that's
what you might expect to conclude if you
are psychoanalytically minded or
maybe psychologically minded but what
really
is the case that what maintains our
sanity is constant receptivity to the
reactions of other people
at least that's part of what maintains
it we have a dialogue with our own
conscience which is something like that
internal spirit that you described
earlier the spirit that animates history
speaking within us
we have a responsibility to that but we
have to be open to other people
especially people who don't
share our opinions because we're stupid
and lost and
it's it's absolutely crucial so i think
that from a psychological perspective i
think that's a great idea
and i mean it also keeps you alive
because then other people are feeding
you
new ideas all the time right and and and
yeah and i think
you know for all of the
downsides of the new york times i think
being around people
you know good faith people and there
were many good faith people who just
disagreed with me and
like i you know i had a wonderful editor
there who you know
was definitely to my left but was such a
fair reader and made everything i wrote
stronger like i
need that yeah everybody thinks that and
one of the things that i think
is one of the beauties of this sort of
like cambrian explosion of the podcast
world and newsletter world in the
patreon world the locals world and the
whatever's going to come before we
publish this world it's amazing because
we can connect directly to an audience
but also like everyone
everyone needs an editor everyone and
everyone needs a community and you know
if your community is only like parroting
back to you the things you believe
that's not a recipe for growth and it's
also a recipe i think for being
captive to who you are in a particular
moment and i really want to make sure
that i'm
giving myself the ability to change and
grow as hard as that might be able to do
in public
well that's the but that's the right
thing to model i think is that
i i believe that when these podcasts
work properly
the reason they're compelling to the
degree they manage to be compelling is
because
what people are observing and
participating in is the process by
which two people mutually transform one
another towards a higher good
and they're like and so we're both
struggling to make things clear and to
to approach something that we don't have
yet but it's in that struggle that's
that the motivation arises but you know
how you and i before this podcast
started both said
like i said to you i'm nervous and you
said i've been nervous for five years
or anxious for five years and i said i
know exactly what you mean like
that's true to some extent but we both
know that we're having this conversation
just the two of us right now
but that it's going to be in public and
that millions of people potentially
could see it
and that ultimately changes the way that
we talk to each other it makes us more
careful
and i think that's that that's a good
thing but the conversation
more nervous yeah and more nervous but
the conversation you and i
might have in private like that's a
different conversation and that that to
me is the most precious kind
because that's like the high trust
i mean obviously i have a high level of
trust enough to be able to come on this
and trust that the conversation is going
to be
fair and good faith and of course i have
that but
like it's still in public right
and yeah my dream is that you know that
these conversations are as close to a
private conversation as
public can as it can possibly be managed
of course
of course but but you see it but it is
that it is
well yeah it's interesting because we've
struggled with this a fair bit because
often at the end of the interview or the
discussion
you know we'll close it and then we'll
keep talking that me and whoever i'm
talking to and then
we'll talk about some things that are
interesting and then you know we have
the decision because we're still
recording often it's like well do we
include that and
generally the answer has been yes
although not always
i mean it's hard to it's interesting
though too because if if you make a
private conversation public
see that is the truth to do that and
then that really shows that you have
trust in your audience is that look i'm
gonna tell you what i actually think i'm
gonna take but then they see
barry too that's that adventure that we
were talking about earlier
that that is being offered by these
radical movements is like
there's something unbelievably
adventurous about telling the truth in
public
because you don't know you see you have
to stake the you have to stake your
faith on the truth in that situation
because you make the presumption that
that's the best possible approach for it
even though you don't know what's going
to happen
you hedge your bets otherwise right and
you're more conservative and you're more
cautious because
well because you want to direct what's
going to happen even though you really
can't but to the degree that you can
throw that off and say well to hell with
it
so to speak i'm going to say what i
think and um
but that's also when the when these
things really take off
when the discussions really take off i
agree and i just
for for me you know now that i'm doing
well in sub stack and i'm building my
my company it's like
i can tell like i can tell the truth
telling the truth has sort of
it's good for business for me but what
about like
the young the young person right who
like
hasn't even started their career it
seems to me that
the pr i guess what i'm trying to say is
the price of telling the truth
is so high well i i've thought about
that a lot you know and
in my first book i learned a fair bit of
this from reading nietzsche i would say
but there is an emphasis in nietzsche's
thinking on the necessity for an
apprenticeship like let's say you're a
young person well and you don't really
know how to express yourself and you
don't really know anything yet and so
what you have to do to some degree is
subjugate yourself
to a disciplinary process and that means
that your particular
voice is temporarily it's not suppressed
exactly it's
it's subordinated yeah right but it's
subordinated to authority not to power
and then
you go through that that that
apprenticeship process which
for you would have happened to some
degree in college and then to some
degree at the wall street journal
you go through that subordination
process and discipline yourself
and then you can start integrating who
you are
with the discipline and then speaking
well this
this is the thing that i think some
people in
our in like let's say the independent
like the wild west
universe do not appreciate about what
the institutions at their best
can do which is exactly what you're
describing it's
the training and the raising up and the
elevation of the younger generation
and of other voices and and that's not
their exploitation
no and i want to figure out how can i do
that
how can i build a version of an
institution
that somehow is immunized or inoculated
from the the ideological takeover that
adheres to the kind of old-school
liberal values that we've talked about
on this podcast
and that allow me to do the thing that i
told you i love doing which yes i love
writing and i
i something about my personality allows
me to be in the arena
much more so than a lot of other people
experiencing an openness
maybe sure you'll find out when you take
the test yes but
but also like i will not be satisfied
if that's the only thing that i do like
i i just know that the reasons that i'm
able to do what i do or
be able to put together a column or know
how to report or
speak in public is because so much
effort on the part of other people went
into training me to be able to do that
yes yes well this is this is something
else and our people talk
about editing but for people that are
like coming up let's say like as
instagram influencers or like
clubhouse personalities or whatever like
that's not that's that's not a
substitute for the kind of process that
i'm describing
it's just really not so you talked about
you can get the substitute to some
degree i suppose by being
carefully responsive to your audience
because they will train you to some
degree but that
then you run into the problem of the
echo chamber the potential echo chamber
developing the positive feedback loop
now there's something here about
judgment
like in our society the idea that you
should become
that you should be non-judgmental has
become a truism
and it's one of those truisms that you
have that you violate at your own peril
but i don't like that at all because if
you're going to be
a good apprentice master let's say what
you
use is your judge judgment's my entire
business
judgment's discernment saying that some
things are worthy and some things aren't
some ideas are worthy
of being heard by the world and some
writers and some voices and some style
and
certain like you want to tell me that
like
you know everyone's as good as joan
didion and we should have no judgment
like give me a
give me right well that's it well right
right well it's certainly the pathway to
insanity because
everything but when people say that it's
like no judgment
it's like good vibes like no yeah yeah
yeah it doesn't mean it
i don't think people understand the
depth of what it means
judgment is essential judgment is
absolutely essential and certainly
essential
if you want to be a good writer well if
you want the good
judgment is inevitable because you have
to differentiate between what
is good and what isn't now now so
how do you construe the relationship
between fostering the development of
someone
and the imposition of that judgment
because
you're going to impose high standards
right and so that means
judgment and judgment means criticism
criticism means this and not this
right it doesn't mean not this it
doesn't mean it's all bad it means well
we'll keep this and we'll
dispense with the rest right it's the
winnowing of the wheat from the chaff
and so how do you construe that in
relationship to mentoring and how do you
do that without becoming an
like a two imposing force
it's very interesting i it's such a
delicate good question
that really comes down to the trust you
develop
with someone and whether or not they
believe that you're
trying to shape them into the best
potential not version of themselves
that's
saying too much but like their talent
becoming
i don't know if it is saying too much i
think i don't think so i think that is
and i do think that's an extension of
the parental place
and that that's the proper way to
control construe the social institution
i would say to to steal a term you know
i do think a safe space is extremely
important
i have been able to hear incredibly
harsh criticism
from people in my life mentors in my
life
i'm thinking now especially back to my
early days at the wall street journal
and
you know people like brett stevens and
paul jagot or melanie kirkpatrick when i
knew it was coming
from a place of genuinely wanting the
best for me
that's really what i mean and right so
you you trusted the sort the judgment
was
and and uh because i think you were on
there because it was connected to like i
admired what they were doing
i saw that it was impressive and good i
saw
even if i disagreed with the view right
the the crap
and i knew that i couldn't do that yet
and right so judgment in the service of
what's admirable and good
is to be devoutly hoped for
yeah yeah and just
it was that's not power but it was just
so obvious to me that i
couldn't do what they could do and that
if i wanted to learn to do what they
could do and what i so desperately
wanted
to be good at for whatever reasons about
my history or
the way i was raised or whatever then i
needed
to like put my ego aside and listen to
them
and sometimes that meant that the things
i wrote they said were
like pretty much garbage yeah well
that's the case though when you start to
write or think is 95
of what you write or think is garbage
and even when you're good at it you have
to
the more you throw away the better in
some sense because you only keep what's
great
if you can manage it and i also think
that like
there's a mimicry in the beginning that
i think is extremely important
yes studying what works and
literally mapping it out you know i was
just yeah that's the humanities by the
way
yeah like that's very
important and that doesn't mean that
you're a parrot and that doesn't mean
that you're you don't have your own
style but like
like you know and now why would you make
that comment about style
well because i think that a lot of
people in my generation are
and especially younger obsessed with
like being singular and
being different from everyone that came
before and
they confused the discipline with the
eradication of their style
i think yeah yeah well it is a fine
discernment
it is and i think that you know you can
i also think
that style has to do with inborn talent
a lot of the time
and that you can learn to be an
excellent like i'm not a great writer
i'm a very good writer but there are
people who are
like just yeah like
cirque du soleil writers yeah okay and
but being a very good writer and being
able to communicate plainly and
compellingly and convincingly
that's more than most people can hope
for
i guess i'm saying that like i think a
lot of young
writers imagine that like they can do
something that no one's ever done before
and it's like why don't we strive for
being able to communicate
really clearly and plainly without
jargon
to someone with only a high school
degree so that they can understand a
complicated test right so that's the
imposition of constraints to begin with
just to develop the discipline of the
craft
and then hopefully you can deviate from
that in a stylistically appropriate
manner as you become an expert
exactly it's just like you're not hunter
s thompson
maybe you could be that but like let's
try and just get the basics down
start basics the basics are hard enough
the basics are hard enough and like
yeah i just think that it sounds so
basic but
but being able to communicate plainly
without
the crutch of jargon is something that
many people that are coming out of
the most celebrated elite prestigious
universities in the north america cannot
do
and i will tell you that when i can find
a young person that can do that
i will i cling to that person that's how
rare it is
and why cling why do you say that
because it's special and rare
it's special and rare to be able to find
someone that
who's who's frankly world view but then
that's reflected in the writing
has not been captured
by so look so it seems so obvious to me
that
it's obvious in in a way that is only
obvious when you realize it but that
when when institutions are functioning
properly they consist of people who are
looking to young people to find
talent in the direction of their
interests and to nurture that
i mean isn't that your you you've
experienced your apprenticeship in this
various institutions is there any
relationships that you've had that you
regard as
intensely positive that weren't of that
nature
that weren't that weren't meant to uh
yeah that that weren't
so i like to think about it as the best
in that person serving the best in you
and when you look back at the people
who've shaped your development
i mean isn't that the nature of the
relationship that you had with them
rather than the relationship of
arbitrary power where they're skimming
off
say the excess profits of your labor
it's not fundamentally
exploitative and that's a sec
overwhelmingly it's been
overwhelmingly it's been the former
positive now that's not to say listen uh
as as you've sort of assessed me without
me taking the personality test yet
i'm also someone that can
piss off a boss because i'm someone who
can
you know swim upstream
by my nature now oftentimes though
that's been a
quality that's appreciated because it's
meant
sometimes in homogeneous environments
that i've been looked to as like a check
on it
so i think that they're they're you know
a good advantage of disagreeable people
is exactly that they will actually tell
you what they think
yeah but sometimes they're right
often we are right i will say but it can
piss people off that are just trying to
kind of like
you know let's get through the day let's
put out the paper it can be annoying
frankly and i know i know that about
myself
but also i think that it can be a
superpower i really do
so what's in the immediate future with
regard to sub stack
and how many subscribers do you have
tell me about tell me the re the end of
the story so now you're on sub stack
oh god there's so much that's happened
um
we've drawn out like a resignation over
two hours but i hope we fit
other things that are of interest into
it um so now i'm on substance
like you know like i think a lot of the
a lot of heterodox journalists who
don't fit in with a tribe are also on
substance and i think it's
extremely interesting the thing that i
think is a challenge it's like an idw of
journalists
yeah i mean the thing that i think is is
challenging right is
if you're like a dentist or an
accountant or a lawyer and i meet a lot
of these people they say i don't trust
the new york times anymore what do i
read
well it's a really dissatisfying answer
because i'm like well
you need to subscribe to these 10 sub
stacks and listen to these five podcasts
and following these 30 people on twitter
no like that's not gonna work so i am
extremely
interested in in what i've been
referring to like how do i make a common
address
for that sensibility that independent
independent-minded
spirit um that you know is not like
centrist in the sense of like just
finding the middle path
but is able to see truth on on
but is able to separate let's say
identity from ideas and is able to say
yeah that person maybe sucks on this
thing but they're really right about
that
like that's what i'm interested in
building and so the way that started off
for me
and i'm proud of it is you know
commissioning op-eds and columns and
reported pieces from
voices that you know don't have the
platform that i think that they should
um and trying to elevate them to my
readers but it's going to be
you know my podcast podcast network and
ultimately i hope
like a whole ecosystem of journalism and
storytelling
um that's what i'm interested in
building and so i have tens of thousands
of subscribers and
that's been fantastic and i'm incredibly
grateful to it
but for me this is just the beginning
and and i i really really
like in the end of the day the reason
that i left the new york times
jordan is that you know yes because i
was being bullied
yes because i couldn't do my job both
true things
but ultimately it's because i really
believe that
the fight for
liberalism and i i don't mean that in
the partisan sense but i mean the kind
of values we've been describing during
this conversation
that like that is more important than
any amount of popularity that any amount
of accolades on twitter
than than anything else than anything
else
and so i had to leave the the
institution
in order to fight for for liberalism
and that i see as like the like the
mission of my life
i guess you know the catastrophe of our
times
yeah but i mean at first especially for
someone who's older like me
you know i mean i had a dream a while
back i i wandered into the backyard of a
cabin that i was staying at and
there was a dying lion by a fire pit
at the boundary of this of this cabin's
property and
my aunt who who's wait an actual dying
lion
this is in a dream oh in a dream in a
dream yes sorry
yes and so so my aunt called to me to
warn me about the presence of this lion
and i looked at it and it was in rough
shape it was mangy and
and ill camped and not good but still
you know a lion and
powerful and then i wandered around to
the left side of the house
and interestingly enough and
there was a whole number of them
tigers lions all these predatory beasts
all in terrible shape and all hungry and
willing to attack and i had to speak in
order to keep them at bay
and i woke up and i thought well jesus
that's pretty bloody obvious i know what
that dream means i mean
there's all these dying lions the new
york times
the legacy medias the institutions i'm
not happy to see their demise
no it's really awful i mean they were
still
and to hear someone like johan mee park
talk about colombia in that way
it's so awful and to see what happened
with you at the new york times
it's like you know one hand the story is
well you know you pursued your creative
spirit and you established yourself
independently and
isn't that wonderful but that loss that
you described of the institution that
has the capacity to apprentice and train
that's cataclysmic
i will say that i spent months i could
kind of cry thinking about it mourning
that like it is
catastrophic um but
there are things in history that have
been more catastrophic
and that's the kind of perspective that
i'm trying to keep because
if i spent all day looking at the
wreckage
and and more than just looking at the
wreckage trying desperately to try and
like shore up something that is so
clearly rotten
i would spend my life in grief and
i just believe so strongly
that not believe i see that people have
had to build
things in way way way
more trying and difficult circumstances
than this
and so if they could build things from
true wreckage believe me
we can rebuild new institutions we can
and that's what i'm gonna do and i think
that's what everyone that comes to me
you know complaining about what's going
on in their kids school or what's going
on in their company
sometimes people that are running the
companies coming to me complaining about
what's happening in their own company
that they have control over
like enough enough like no more
complaining
quietly no more anonymous emails like
the time is
now to out yourself as someone
that is opposed to this that is alarmed
about it
and then spend all of your energy and
money and time
banding together with people to build
new things
i wish there was another option because
that sounds exhausting i realized
but i just don't think there's another
option and
three years ago if you had asked me i
would have suggested something different
i i really believe that a lot of these
institutions can be saved and by the way
some of them
and to the extent to which there are
ones that can be saved and shored up
they should be
because it's really really really really
really hard to build new things
really hard it's so easy to tear things
down
but that's the conclusion that i've come
to and
i think the more people that can yes
like let's grieve the let's grieve the
20th century institutions that are
crumbling
let's understand that they are something
that they might have the same name but
they're no longer what they used to be
and then let's get to work
building the things that we know we need
to build that are necessary for
upholding
the civilization that we talked about
earlier that's what i think the task is
thank you very much for talking with me
today
thank you jordan
it was really good to see you barry it
was great to see you too
[Music]
you